[Music]
i don't know a ton about wrestling but
that's um like the mark of like a like a
very high caliber wrestlers like they
can improv yeah they can do calls like
on the fly i see yeah yeah that makes
sense yeah yeah tony's real good yeah so
it's fun i got powerbomb somebody threw
a table it was just really i lived all
my dreams and then afterwards i went out
and one of my childhood favorite
wrestlers was in the back and he just
got in a too cold scorpio i grew up
watching was a little kid and he was on
this independent show and i didn't even
get to talk i wasn't like i'm not gonna
go talk to real wrestlers and he came up
and he's like oh man he's like he's like
they told me you're not even a wrestler
he's like but she's like but you would
you you damn sure entertainer and i was
like man
damn that's so sick high praise yeah
yeah the the
i mean this gets it gets so wild i
that's the only commentary i'm going to
throw out there because i don't want to
spoil it yeah i guess people should just
go watch this yeah
um
so your prep that's interesting so you
train at santino bros and then you were
like this is a little two yeah cause
they were like
you started
[Music]
considering your regular job
oh
my god
i already went through this comedy
[Laughter]
i know how this plays out did you go to
like their little like storage unit with
the ring in it oh yeah yeah yeah i went
for like three months i went for you
know was it like three hour class yeah
three months you went there yeah running
back and forth
that full hour pre-hour before you even
get to do any of the moves yeah i really
it was you know and i never
i never done like team sports or
anything like that in high school so it
was kind of my first time doing anything
like that so i actually i hated it and i
loved it i threw up i threw up a couple
times no way yeah i mean i i don't doubt
it i think we were ready to puke after
like a half day in that thing again it
got so hot so hot unbelievably hot yeah
and they're like hey
you know half of you are going to take
these bumps in the ring the other half
just use this little wrestling mat yeah
on the concrete yeah i don't
i don't know about this anymore yeah can
we pull up like just like a little bit
of us all right so our i want to see it
so we
we shot this video for like a like a
live stream that we did
and we yeah we went to santino bros
dressed like this because we were like
trying to play characters
yeah clearly we're the ultimate warrior
influences very obvious but
you know
we're basic [ __ ] when it comes to
wrestling knowledge but
[Laughter]
but
um
yeah so like cody's saying we come in
there with you know with this uniform
we're thinking they're gonna sort of
like appreciate it like okay they're
trying to get into it and they were just
like just stone cold they were like
i feel like we kind of disrespected yeah
them and the the establishment a little
bit because we were like
we kind of came in we're like
not being that serious about it but
that's the whole point is like learning
what it takes yeah and they whipped us
into shape like they really did yeah so
by the end we had a whole new
appreciation for just like oh wrestling
did they chop you at all oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah what was um
what's the big guy's name again um was
it the big guy there the time brody was
it brody king no it wasn't brody it's uh
the big latino guy's dad was a wrestler
um yeah i took like i took like three or
four i was like give him to me like for
real and he like let me feel it
and then but he hit me with one to kind
of like get my energy sparked up
and that one was hard as hell
i felt that one like the rest of the day
yeah that's the thing that sucks is that
you're like oh how do we learn how to
fake these childs he's like no you just
learn how to take them yeah just learn
how to get slapped in your titties real
hard
yeah that's literally it and i remember
we hit each other with a few good ones
in the moment we were kind of like oh
wow that [ __ ]
that's not good no people get their
chest caved in something yeah yeah
especially uh the dude who hit me i mean
his hand was like as big as my chest so
i felt that i feel like people don't i
never realized that about wrestling that
it's like 95 percent real oh like when
you get slapped or like thrown through a
table or whatever that shit's out it's
just happening yeah yeah you were
actually feeling those yeah yeah no like
when we were setting up my match um the
guy called me out and then he slapped me
and some of the p and i fall down and
some people were like oh you got to
learn how to take that slap better and
not fall like that and i was like i
didn't have any choice yeah
[Laughter]
yeah the fake the only fake part of
wrestling is maybe like the storyline
but that i think that's what gets
interesting about wrestling that people
don't really
get either is the fact that
you know you can make [ __ ] personal in
wrestling like depending on how you
wrestle that person and
um there's a whole thing right now where
guys are mad at each other because the
one guy calls the guy fat and now they
like they they might not fight because
if they fight they might fight for real
oh wow that makes it interesting yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah see that's like that's
the meta on wrestling that i think
people always
don't
get just as outsiders like oh why do
people watch this it's like no it's this
weird
baked in drama that
isn't always on the surface i've i've
brought this up twice on our show wait
what i'm just watching this oh yeah
reliving these moments yeah yeah
yeah i like your hair better now
i don't know what i was thinking yeah
that's a bit much oh
i have to say this was after we did this
though it made me we i mean we came away
from it we're like dude we got to do
this in front of a crowd this would be
you know real like no other because
normally because you you know comedy
it's like
so fun that thrill of making someone
laugh give you that rush right yeah and
i never felt the thrill of like someone
caring about you yeah you're getting
hurt yeah like when i got hit and then
people go oh
oh that's cool oh that's so different
yeah feeling it yeah it was really fun
real fun i really enjoyed it it must be
interesting too
because especially
you know before you become like a
household name i would even say like
even in aew and
even in the bigger leagues you're still
gonna have those moments where the crowd
like maybe is skeptical on your
character they don't really like you so
that's got to be a pretty intense thing
when that first time where you win a big
crowd like that on your side in that
type of performance i feel like that's
just got to feel crazy or it must be
extra shitty if they
hate you oh yeah you're one of the
disliked people yeah
unless you want to be healed yeah if you
want to be even if you don't want to be
and they tell you you are you're like i
guess i'll just be that yeah you know
yeah that was like at the beginning of
the thing we were like choreographing
the
the match or whatever and they were like
who wants to be the bad guy yeah and we
were like oh [ __ ] and then they pointed
at cody yeah oh yeah they pointed cody
they were like well he's kind of the
pretty boy he looks like softer and
nicer so look at that [ __ ] hair yeah
yeah what an idiot
you're the best yeah yeah so i ended up
being the heel which was fine it made
the story like fun in the context of the
ring did you like being a bad guy yeah i
mean i think i i generally oh yeah you
were the bad guy yeah yeah i thought i
was no no no i generally enjoy being a
little [ __ ] sometimes so i i was kind of
liking the the the heel aspect it was
definitely fun
you